Today we're going to talk about the most frequently diagnosed personality disorder that many of you may never have heard of. But if you have, you might not really understand what it is because even its name is somewhat enigmatic. Borderline personality disorder is a condition marked by intense emotions that are typically hostile, angry, or depressive in nature. People with BPD may have a history of impulsive behavior and chaotic relationships. Many fear being abandoned and may tend to see the world as purely black or white. Some engage in self-harm or suicidal ideation, and what may be the most challenging about this disorder is that many people with BPD are able to project an appearance of total normalcy.
今天我们要讨论的是一种最常被诊断出来，但你们许多人可能从未听说过的人格障碍。但如果你听说过，你可能并不真正了解它是什么，因为即使是它的名字也有些令人费解。边缘型人格障碍（BPD）是一种以强烈情绪为特征的疾病，这些情绪通常具有敌意、愤怒或抑郁的性质。BPD患者可能有冲动行为和混乱人际关系的历史。许多人害怕被抛弃，往往倾向于以非黑即白的方式看待世界。有些人会进行自残或有自杀念头，而这种障碍最棘手的地方在于，许多BPD患者能够表现出完全正常的样子。
So what makes borderline personality disorder its own diagnosis? How does it affect people's trajectory in life? How is it different from other personality disorders? How might you tell if someone you know has, it or if you yourself might have it. And if people with BPD are high functioning and appear quote unquote normal, how can the disorder be diagnosed and treated? Is it really a discrete mental illness? And what makes BPD controversial among mental health researchers and practitioners? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
那么，是什么让边缘型人格障碍成为一种独立的诊断呢？它如何影响人们的人生轨迹？它与其他人格障碍有何不同？你如何判断你认识的人是否患有此病，或者你自己是否可能患有此病？如果BPD患者功能良好且看起来“所谓”正常，那么这种障碍该如何诊断和治疗？它真的是一种离散的心理疾病吗？为什么BPD在心理健康研究人员和从业者中存在争议？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》。
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim, Mills. My guest today is Dr. Carla Sharp, Professor and Associate Dean for Faculty and Research at the University of Houston. She is also director of the University's Adolescent Diagnosis Assessment Prevention and Treatment Center and the Developmental Psychopathology Lab. She holds adjunct positions at the University of Texas, Baylor College of Medicine, University College London, and the University of the Free State in South Africa. Dr. Sharp has a longstanding interest in social cognition as a cause and correlate of psychiatric disorders across the lifespan with a special focus on youth. She has published over 300 peer-reviewed articles, numerous chapters, and eight books. A large
该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是休斯顿大学教授兼教职与研究副院长卡拉·夏普博士。她同时也是该大学青少年诊断评估预防与治疗中心以及发展心理病理学实验室的主任。她在德克萨斯大学、贝勒医学院、伦敦大学学院和南非自由州大学担任兼职职务。夏普博士长期关注社会认知作为跨生命周期精神障碍的成因和相关因素，特别关注青少年群体。她已发表了300多篇同行评审文章、众多章节和八本书。她的大部分
proportion of her research uses borderline personality disorder and other personality pathology to study where social cognitive function goes awry. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. Sharp. Thank you so much, Kim. I'm so glad to be here with you talking about this topic that's very clear. close to my heart. Well, let's start by talking about personality disorders in general. How does psychology categorize and define personality and personality disorders? And how is this area of psychology evolving? Well, that is a very big question, and I'm going to try and keep it succinct. The diagnosis of personality disorder is a disorder or a diagnosis in transition. For the last 20 to 30 years, since the publication of the DSM 3, we have been ascribing to a system of diagnosing
研究都利用边缘型人格障碍和其他人格病理学来研究社会认知功能在何处出现偏差。感谢您今天接受我的采访，夏普博士。非常感谢，金。我很高兴能在这里与你讨论这个我非常关心的话题。那么，让我们先从人格障碍的总体情况谈起。心理学是如何分类和定义人格及人格障碍的？这一心理学领域又是如何演变的？嗯，这是一个非常宏大的问题，我会尽量简明扼要地回答。人格障碍的诊断是一个处于转型期的诊断。在过去的20到30年里，自《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》第三版（DSM-3）发布以来，我们一直采用一种诊断系统，
personality disorder that we call the categorical system. It is based on a medical model in the sense that we see disorder as something that a person has or does not have. You can think a little bit about pregnancy as an example. You know, you can't be halfway pregnant. You're either pregnant or you're not pregnant. And in the same way in the categorical system, diagnosis, we view someone as having a personality disorder or they don't have a personality disorder. Now, this has been the way we've diagnosed personality disorder since the DSM3, which was published in the 1980s. However, over the last 20 to 30 years, we have discovered that this categorical system has some limitations to fully understanding and treating personality disorder.
我们称之为分类系统。它基于医学模型，即我们将障碍视为一个人“有”或“没有”的东西。你可以把怀孕作为一个例子。你知道，人不可能处于“半怀孕”状态。你要么怀孕了，要么没怀孕。同样，在分类诊断系统中，我们认为某人要么患有人格障碍，要么没有。自20世纪80年代出版DSM-3以来，我们一直以这种方式诊断人格障碍。然而，在过去的20到30年里，我们发现这种分类系统在全面理解和治疗人格障碍方面存在一些局限性。
So one of the important data points in this regard is that when we take all of the personality disorder symptoms, and I should just explain first that there are in the categorical system, there are 10 personality disorder, 10 categories of personality disorder. And one of them is, for instance, BPD that you mentioned, borderline personality disorder. Another one is narcissistic personality disorder. A third one is antisocial personality disorder. So there's 10 of these personality disorders in the current system of diagnosing personality disorders.
在这方面，一个重要的数据点是，当我们汇总所有人格障碍的症状时——我应该先解释一下，在分类系统中，有10种人格障碍类别。其中之一就是你提到的BPD，即边缘型人格障碍。另一种是自恋型人格障碍。第三种是反社会型人格障碍。所以，在现行的人格障碍诊断系统中，有这10种人格障碍。
When you take all of the symptoms of those 10 personal disorders and you put them together into a big factor analysis, you would expect you will get 10 factors pushed out by the factor analysis. This is how factor analysis work. If we want to understand a particular phenomenon, we put the signs and symptoms. of that phenomena into a factor analysis and we get one dimension out that explains that phenomenon. In the case of personality disorder, we want to be able to see if they really exist in nature, like the DSM would suggest, we want to be able to see 10 personality disorders come out
当你把这10种人格障碍的所有症状放在一起进行大规模的因子分析时，你本应期望因子分析会得出10个因子。这就是因子分析的工作原理。如果我们想了解某种特定现象，我们会把该现象的体征和症状放入因子分析中，然后得出一个解释该现象的维度。在人格障碍的情况下，如果我们想看看它们是否真的像DSM所暗示的那样在自然界中存在，我们希望看到因子分析能得出10种人格障碍。
of a factor analysis. So we want to see the symptoms of BPD hang together to form borderline personality disorder. We want to see the symptoms of narcissistic personality disorder to hang together to form narcissistic personality disorder. Same with antisocial, same with avoidance, same with histrionic, all of those 10 personality disorders. What happens in actual fact when you put all of those symptoms into a factor analysis, it's a big mishmash of dimensions and none of these categories come out very clearly. And so this has been one of the first and most important signs that these categories don't exist in nature as we have always thought they did. In fact, when you do meet criteria for something like BPD, you probably also meet criteria for two or three
所以我们希望看到BPD的症状聚在一起形成边缘型人格障碍。我们希望看到自恋型人格障碍的症状聚在一起形成自恋型人格障碍。反社会型、回避型、表演型也是如此，所有这10种人格障碍都应如此。但实际上，当你把所有这些症状放入因子分析时，结果是一团混乱的维度，没有任何类别能清晰地显现出来。因此，这是这些类别并不像我们一直认为的那样在自然界中存在的首要且最重要的迹象之一。事实上，当你符合像BPD这样的诊断标准时，你很可能也符合其他两三种
other personality disorders. When you do meet criteria for BPD, you probably also meet criteria, this makes a picture even more complex, for depression and anxiety and substance use disorder. We are now at a point in our history in the field where we have decided to move away from this categorical system of personality disorder diagnosis. to what we call a more dimensional system. And so when you open the diagnostic and statistical manual for mental disorders, the DSM, the fifth edition was published in 2013. When you open the DSM, you will actually find two parallel systems for diagnosing personality disorder. In section two of the DSM, you will find the old 10 categories. BPD will be there, narcissism will be there,
人格障碍的诊断标准。当你符合BPD标准时，你可能也符合抑郁症、焦虑症和物质使用障碍的诊断标准，这使得情况变得更加复杂。我们现在处于该领域历史上的一个节点，决定放弃这种人格障碍的分类诊断系统，转向我们所说的更具维度的系统。因此，当你打开《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）时——第五版于2013年出版——你会发现诊断人格障碍的两种平行系统。在DSM的第二部分，你会找到旧的10种类别。BPD会在那里，自恋会在那里，
antisocial and so forth. They will all be there. But when you page, forward, you will find in Section 3, the alternative model for personality disorder. And this is the dimensional model for personality disorder. And that is where we are moving towards in the future. And I could tell you a little bit more about what that means and why that is important that we are moving towards this dimension. But I'll stop therefore now and see if you have any follow-up questions about just the categories to start with. Well, it's very complex. and it's got to be a challenge then for clinicians who are trying to come up with a diagnosis. I mean, how could you actually say somebody has BPD if it overlaps with so many other things?
反社会等等。它们都会在那里。但当你往后翻，你会发现第三部分中有人格障碍的替代模型。这就是人格障碍的维度模型。这就是我们未来发展的方向。我可以再多告诉你一些这意味着什么，以及为什么我们向这个维度发展很重要。但我现在先停在这里，看看你对这些类别是否有后续问题。嗯，这非常复杂。对于试图做出诊断的临床医生来说，这一定是个挑战。我的意思是，如果BPD与这么多其他疾病重叠，你怎么能断定某人患有BPD呢？
Or there are a certain number of traits, a kind of formula that says this person has BPD or has a different disorder? Well, at the moment, at present, when we use Section 2 of the DSM, which is what most clinicians still use, clinicians find it relatively straightforward to diagnose someone with BPD in the sense that there are nine criteria. So, you know, those criteria are affective instability, so mood instability, anger, suicidality, emptiness, identity disturbance, abandonment fears, relationship problems, and impulsivity. And so when a clinician meets someone and the person tells them that, you know, they don't know what's going on with them. They have a lot of relationship difficulties. They've been on an SSRI for a long time, doesn't seem to be helping.
或者是否存在一定数量的特征，某种公式来判定这个人患有BPD还是其他障碍？嗯，目前，当我们使用DSM的第二部分（大多数临床医生仍在使用）时，临床医生发现诊断BPD相对直接，因为有九项标准。所以，这些标准包括情感不稳定性（即情绪不稳定）、愤怒、自杀倾向、空虚感、身份认同障碍、被抛弃恐惧、人际关系问题和冲动性。当临床医生遇到某人，而对方告诉他们自己不知道怎么了，有很多人际关系困难，长期服用SSRIs（选择性5-羟色胺再摄取抑制剂）却似乎没有帮助。
They've tried all kinds of therapy. Doesn't seem to be helping. They still have lots of relationship difficulties. They're self-harm. They're suicidal. The clinician will start thinking this may be personality. disorder because the person is not responding to traditional treatment approaches for depression, anxiety, substance abuse. Usually that tells us that there's something extra going on in the
他们尝试过各种治疗，似乎都没有用。他们仍然有很多人际关系困难。他们有自残行为，有自杀倾向。临床医生就会开始考虑这可能是人格障碍，因为患者对传统的抑郁、焦虑、药物滥用治疗方法没有反应。通常这告诉我们，在人格功能领域还有其他问题存在。
personality functioning domain. And so the clinician can then go through those nine criteria, and if the person meets five or more of those nine borderline criteria, then the person is deemed to be meeting criteria, clinical threshold for borderline personality disorder. And that's all fine and the clinician will then simply do what they do currently, which is diagnose BPD, diagnose depression, anxiety, substance use disorder, which usually hang together. If they explore a different personality disorder, a person may then meet criteria for another personality disorder as well. And all of that information goes into the person's chart and the clinician has the job to treat all of this co-occurring disorders at the same time.
因此，临床医生可以对照那九项标准，如果一个人符合这九项边缘型标准中的五项或更多，那么该人就被认为达到了边缘型人格障碍的临床阈值。这没问题，临床医生会像目前所做的那样，诊断BPD，同时诊断通常会共存的抑郁症、焦虑症、物质使用障碍。如果他们探索另一种人格障碍，患者可能还会符合另一种人格障碍的标准。所有这些信息都会进入患者的病历，临床医生有责任同时治疗所有这些共存的障碍。
And I think that is okay. That's how we've been functioning for the last 30 years. And we have moderate success with that. Once a person's been diagnosed with BPD, they usually get one of the frontline treatments for BPD, which is either dialectical behavior therapy, which is most common in the US, or they would get mentalization-based therapy,
我认为这还可以。这就是我们过去30年的运作方式。我们对此有中等的成功率。一旦一个人被诊断为BPD，他们通常会接受BPD的一线治疗，即辩证行为疗法（在美国最常见），或者他们会接受心智化疗法，
which is more common in Europe. There are some other treatment approaches, too, that are evidence-based, like transference-focused therapy, schemer-focused therapy. And actually there's good evidence showing that good old CBT can actually be helpful for people with BPD as well. So there are ways in which we, that's right, cognitive behavioral therapy. So there are ways that this system has worked well enough, but we think we can do better.
这在欧洲更常见。还有一些其他基于证据的治疗方法，如移情焦点治疗、图式疗法。事实上，有充分证据表明，老派的CBT（认知行为疗法）对BPD患者也很有帮助。所以，是的，认知行为疗法。这个系统运作得还算可以，但我们认为我们可以做得更好。
We think with a new system of diagnosis, we can actually be more precise, in diagnosing people with personality disorder more generally. But we can also just make it a little less complex than having this co-occurring mismatch of disorders that each require their own manualized treatment. So the field has been looking for common factors, common dimensions that is shared by all of the personality pathology so that we can simplify this very complex process
我们认为通过新的诊断系统，我们可以更精确地诊断人格障碍患者。我们也可以让它不那么复杂，不必面对这种需要各自手册化治疗的共存障碍的混乱局面。因此，该领域一直在寻找所有人格病理学共有的共同因素和维度，以便我们能够简化这个我目前概述的非常复杂的过程。
that I've so far outlined. So how debilitating is BPD among the constellation of personality disorders? I think it is the most diagnosed personality disorder, and that is partly due to the fact that BPD appears to capture something that is common among all of the personality disorders. And I do want to talk a little bit about this dimension that I've been mentioning that is shared by all of the personality disorder.
那么，在众多人格障碍中，BPD的致残程度如何？我认为它是被诊断最多的人格障碍，这部分是因为BPD似乎捕捉到了所有人格障碍共有的某种东西。我确实想谈谈我提到的那个所有人格障碍共有的维度。
So what is this dimensional approach that the field is moving towards that helps us better define personality disorder? So if you, I'm going to go back to factor analysis, which I introduced a little bit earlier, as a way of legitimizing disorders, right? If you actually do factor analyze all of the symptoms of personality disorder, what you do get out of that factor analysis in more recent studies is what we call a general factor, a general factor of personality functioning. Now, if your listeners have been hearing about how IQ works in the past, they will know that when we think about IQ, we think about a person with an IQ of 100 as having
那么，该领域正在转向的这种维度方法是什么？它如何帮助我们更好地定义人格障碍？如果你回到我之前介绍的因子分析（作为一种使障碍合法化的方式），如果你确实对人格障碍的所有症状进行了因子分析，在最近的研究中，你得到的是我们所说的“一般因素”，即人格功能的一般因素。如果你的听众过去听说过智商（IQ）是如何运作的，他们就会知道，当我们考虑智商时，我们认为智商为100的人具有
average IQ. And we think about a person as having an IQ of 120 as above average. And a person with 140 as superior, right? And we would also think about someone at 70 as someone who is lower in IQ. So there's a common dimension, a general factor of intelligence. Now, within that general factor of intelligence, we can think about people that are very good at math, but not so good at language, or people that are very fast at processing speed, but they're not so good at math. So we can think about specific ways in which people differ on specific aspects of intelligence, even though their average, their general IQ, can be at a certain level. The field of personality has moved in that same direction, where we, rather than thinking
平均智商。我们认为智商120的人高于平均水平，140的人是优异的，对吧？我们也会认为70的人智商较低。所以，存在一个共同的维度，即智力的一般因素。现在，在那个智力的一般因素内，我们可以考虑那些非常擅长数学但不擅长语言的人，或者处理速度非常快但不擅长数学的人。所以，即使人们的平均智商处于某个水平，我们也可以考虑他们在智力的特定方面存在差异。人格领域也朝着同样的方向发展，我们不再考虑
about the 10 categories, we are now thinking about a general personality functioning, a sort of personality quotient, if you will, rather than an intelligence quotient. Rather than IQ, we can think about personality quotient. And what we want to talk about when we think about your personality functioning is how good are you at managing yourself in the context of interpersonal interactions? How good are you at reading other people's interactions, reading their minds, and managing yourself when you are busy interacting with other people? So the shorthand version of this is adaptive or maladaptive self.
那10个类别，而是现在考虑一般人格功能，如果你愿意，可以称之为“人格商”，而不是智商。与其说智商，不如说人格商。当我们思考你的人格功能时，我们想谈论的是：你在人际互动中管理自己的能力如何？你在解读他人的互动、解读他们的想法以及在与他人互动时管理自己的能力如何？所以，简而言之，这就是适应性或非适应性的自我和人际功能。
and interpersonal functioning. And that appears to be the general factor of personality functioning. How good are we at managing the self in the context of our attachment relationships? How good are we at managing the self in the context of interpersonal relationships? If you're good at that, then you have a high personality quotient. You're doing pretty good on your personality functioning. If you're poor at that and you get dysregulated really easily, you get defensive really easily, you start compensating in the interpersonal interactions, you get confused about what's in your mind and what's in the mind of other people. You start projecting what's in your mind onto other people. You start blaming people and not owning what's going on for you rather than taking
这似乎就是人格功能的一般因素。我们在依恋关系中管理自我的能力如何？我们在人际关系中管理自我的能力如何？如果你擅长这一点，那么你就有很高的人格商。你在人格功能方面做得相当不错。如果你在这方面很差，很容易失调，很容易产生防御心理，开始在人际互动中进行补偿，对自己的想法和他人的想法感到困惑。你开始把你脑子里的东西投射到别人身上。你开始责怪别人，而不是承认自己身上发生了什么，而不是为自己在关系破裂中的贡献承担责任。当我们处于那个领域时，我们说你的“人格商”很低。你在人格功能领域做得不太好。
responsibility for your contribution to the breakdown in a relationship. When we are in that domain, we are saying you've got low personality quotient. You're not doing so well in the personality functioning domain. And it seems that all that this dimension is the common factor for all personality disorder, whether you've got BPD or narcissistic personality or antisocial. All people who have problems in personality functioning struggle to manage themselves, to regulate their self in the context of interpersonal interactions. So to get back to your question, you know, how debilitating is BPD? BPD is debilitating, but I would, I think we, we're at time where we want to move away from the concept of BPD per se and just think about the general
而且似乎这个维度是所有人格障碍的共同因素，无论你是患有BPD、自恋型人格还是反社会型人格。所有在人格功能上有问题的人，都在努力管理自己，在人际互动中调节自己的自我。所以回到你的问题，BPD的致残程度如何？BPD是致残的，但我认为我们现在处于一个想要摆脱BPD本身的概念，只考虑作为非适应性自我和人际功能的人格功能的一般因素的时代，我们都在这个连续体上。你知道，我有状态良好的人格日，那时我调节得很好；我也有状态糟糕的人格日，那时我调节得不太好。我们都能感同身受。问题是，在人际互动中调节自己的能力方面，我大多数日子是否能达到平均水平？如果不能，那么我就需要寻求帮助，因为我可能在关系领域存在问题，需要特定类型的治疗才能好转。
factor of personality functioning as maladaptive self and interpersonal functioning and that we all lie on a continuum there. You know, I have good personality days where I'm well regulated and I have bad personality days where I'm not so well regulated. We all can identify with that. The question is do I get over, you know, average on most days in terms of of my ability to regulate myself in the context of interpersonal interactions. And if I do, then I need to seek help because then I probably have problems in the relational domain that needs a specific kind of treatment in order for it to get better. Right, right. So if it's interfering with your everyday life, then you should seek some treatment. I was going to just say,
对，对。所以如果它干扰了你的日常生活，那么你应该寻求治疗。我正想说，如果你在工作中难以与人相处，在个人生活中也难以与人相处，那么你可能就是一个在人格功能上有困难的人，你需要向专家或了解人格的人寻求帮助。我想问一个非常基本的问题，即在BPD的背景下，“边缘”这个词的含义是什么？边界在哪里？这是一个非常好的问题。这也是一个非常有趣的问题，因为最初当斯皮策（Spitzer）创造这个术语时，他实际上试图阐明精神病（psychosis）和神经症（neurosis）之间的边界。这是60多年前的事了。
if you're struggling at work to get on with people, and if you're struggling in your personal life to get on with people, then you know you're probably someone that struggles with personality functioning and you need to seek help from an expert or people that understand personality. So I wanted to ask a really basic question, which is what is the meaning of the term borderline in the context of BPD? What's the border between? That's a really good question. And it is a very interesting question as well because originally when the term was coined by Spitzer, he actually tried to articulate the border between psychosis and neurosis. And this was, you know, 60 years ago, more than 60 years ago. And at that time,
那时，我们认为精神疾病要么是精神病，要么是神经症。神经症是抑郁症、焦虑症等，没有发生真正的现实脱节。精神病是发生现实脱节的疾病，如精神分裂症。人格病理学之所以如此有趣，是因为它确实两者都不是，它比神经症多一点，但比精神病少一点。所以BPD或人格病理学患者并没有经历真正的现实脱节。但有时他们看起来有点像精神病，因为他们对正在发生的事情的看法显得非常固定。在没有任何充分证据的情况下，他们对别人在想什么的想法几乎可以被视为有点妄想。
we thought about mental illness either as psychotic or neurotic. The neurotic disorders are, you know, the depression, anxiety disorders where there's not a real break with reality occurring. The psychotic disorders are the ones where there is a break with reality occurring like in schizophrenia. What makes personality pathology so interesting is that it really is neither, it's a little bit more than neuroticism, but a little bit less than psychoticism. So people with BPD or personality pathology, they don't experience a true break with reality. But sometimes they appear a bit psychotic because they seem so fixed and really, it in their view on what's going on. They could almost come across as being a bit delusional in what they think someone else is thinking about them in the absence of any good evidence. And so
这让人们认为这看起来像精神病，但它并不是真正的精神病。它当然不像精神分裂症那样对抗精神病药物有反应。但它也不像神经症那样温和，神经症患者有良好的现实检验能力，容易被说服。有时很难与BPD或人格障碍患者讲道理，因为他们对现实的看法变得非常非常固定。在心智化疗法中，我们称之为“心理等同”。我脑子里的东西就是真实的。帮助他们摆脱这种非常固定的想法，即你脑子里的东西实际上是对现实的表征。它不一定能完美地映射到现实上。它是一种我们可以测试、探索并进行验证以查看其真实性的现实表征。所以这就是“边缘”最初的意思。
that has made people think this looks like psychosis, but it isn't really psychosis. And it certainly doesn't respond to antipsychotics like schizophrenia word. But it's not as mild as neurosis, where there is a good sort of reality testing and a person can be easily, you know, reasoned with. It's very difficult sometimes with a person with BPD or personality disorder to reason with them because they get very, very fixed in their view of reality. And we call that in mentalization-based therapy, we call that psychic equivalence. What is in my mind is true. and to help they move away from this very fixed idea that what's actually in your mind is a
那么，你在青少年群体中诊断BPD方面做了一些开创性的工作。你能谈谈这个吗？我的意思是，青春期是一个充满风暴般情绪、喜怒无常、困惑的时期。我的意思是，当一个孩子还在经历所有这些发展动荡时，你怎么能诊断他患有BPD呢？哦，当然。你是对的。直到大约10到15年前，尽管DSM允许在18岁以下的年轻人中诊断BPD，但我们确实很少这样做。因为关于年轻人的人格和人格功能存在一些神话，其中之一就是我们认为人格在人们达到18岁之前是不稳定的。而且，你知道，人们认为当你18岁生日后的第19年醒来时，突然间你就有了稳定的人格，而昨天还没有。
representation of reality. It doesn't necessarily map onto reality perfectly. It's a representation of reality that we can test and explore and put to the test to see how true it actually is. So that was what border originally meant. So one of the areas where you have done some groundbreaking work is around diagnosing BPD in younger people in adolescence. Can you talk about that? I mean, adolescence is a time of stormy emotions, moodiness, confusion. I mean, how could you diagnose a kid as having BPD when,
当然，那是不对的。我们现在从儿童的气质研究中知道，实际上小婴儿来到这个世界上时，就带有非常稳定的接近和回避行为模式。有些婴儿是爱笑、开放的婴儿，他们喜欢新的体验。有些婴儿是回避型婴儿。他们只是需要环境提供更多一点帮助来让他们感到平静。所以这些是气质特征，当他们开始与环境互动时，这些特征就变成了人格特征。事实证明，这些稳定性系数在儿童和青少年中与在成人中一样稳定。所以关于人格在青春期不稳定的想法，几年前就已经被基本推翻了。
you know, he or she is still going through all of this developmental turmoil? Oh, absolutely. So you're right. We, up until about 10, 15 years ago, even though it was allowed in the DSA to diagnose BPD, and a young person and a person below 18 years of age, we really did it. Because there were these myths about personality and personality functioning in young people, one of the things that we thought was that personality wasn't stable until people reached the age of 18. And, you know, when you wake up with your 19th year after your 18th birthday, people thought, you know, suddenly you had a stable personality and yesterday you didn't.
人们持有的另一个想法是，你知道，人格障碍倾向存在一种规范性的增加，你知道，正如你所说，所有青少年都更情绪化。他们确实变得更冲动。他们都更以自我为中心。这是规范性的。那么我们如何知道一个冲动、情绪化和自我中心的15岁孩子是患有自恋型人格障碍还是BPD呢？
Of course, that's not true. We now know from temperamental research in children that actually little babies coming to the world with very, quite stable patterns of approach and avoidance behavior. Some babies are smiley, open babies, and they like new experiences. And some babies are avoidance babies. And they just need a little bit more from the environment to help them feel calm. And so those are temperamental traits that become personality traits as they begin to interact. with the environment. And so these stability coefficients turn out to be as stable in children, adolescents, as they are in adults. So the idea that personality isn't stable in adolescence
这就是人们持有的另一个神话，使他们不愿在年轻人中诊断BPD，他们认为，好吧，他们会长大的。事实证明，在青春期表现出那种规范性边缘型特征增加的年轻人中，有很大一部分并没有“长大”。因此，判断这个年轻人是否处于在整个青春期保持高水平边缘型特征的轨迹上，而不是像同龄人那样真正下降，仍然是一个重要的临床决定。因为规范性的增加最终显示出在25岁左右边缘型特征会再次出现规范性的下降，大多数年轻人会正常化，他们不会表现出像15、16岁时那种情绪失调的动荡。
was pretty much debunked a few years ago already. The other idea that people had was that, you know, there is this normative increase in personality. flavored disorder, you know, all adolescents, like you said, are a bit more emotional. They do get more impulsive. They are a little bit more self-centered, all of them. And that is normative. So how do we know whether a 15-year-old who is impulsive and emotional and egocentric have narcissistic personality disorder or whether they have BPD?
但一部分年轻人会陷入困境。因此，临床医生的工作变成了能够预测谁会陷入困境，谁不会。当我在我们的诊所看到15岁、符合BPD标准的年轻人时，我通常会查看一些保护性因素，以决定这是一个会陷入困境的年轻人，还是一个会表现出规范性下降的年轻人？我会对家长说，你知道，你的孩子现在符合BPD的五项标准，但我认为这种情况不会持续，因为我可以看到，孩子在家里得到了很多支持。你在情感内容方面放慢了节奏。你对她很有耐心。你陪伴着她。你验证她的情绪。你在这里向我们寻求帮助。这是一个好迹象。我们需要确保她有生活，她继续参加体育和文化活动，这样她就能继续感到参与。这里是我们能做的所有事情，
And so that was the other, one of the other myths that people had and made them reluctant to to diagnose BPD in young people, they thought, well, they'll grow out of it. Turns out that a good proportion of young people who show that normative increase in borderline traits during adolescence do not grow out of it. And so it still is an important clinical decision to make whether this young person, are they on a trajectory to stay high in terms of borderline traits through adolescence and never really go down again like their peers, because what the normative increase eventually shows a normative decrease again
来支持人格的巩固。但有时我看到一个没有这些保护性因素的年轻人。然后我会告诉家长，你知道，我确实认为这里存在一些风险，她可能会陷入困境，随着她走出青春期，她可能不会从这些症状中得到缓解。但这是我认为我们需要做的事情，以确保她表现出同龄人会有的规范性下降。所以我认为这成为了临床医生的决策点，你知道，环境中有哪些其他保护性因素可以帮助年轻人跟随同龄人走上规范趋势，而不是陷入困境并继续在整个青春期和成年早期保持这种边缘型特征的升高。
in borderline traits by about 25 years of age, most young people normalize, and they don't show this sort of upheaval in terms of emotion dysregulation that they showed when they were 15 and 16. But a proportion of young people get stuck. And so the clinician's job becomes to be able to predict who's going to be stuck and who's not going to be stuck. When I see young people in our clinic, who's 15, who meet criteria for BPD,
所以我想多谈谈家长的参与。我想知道关于BPD成因的理论。所以，如果你恰好是一个边缘型家长的孩子，你可能会学习这些行为并开始在年轻时表现出来，还是这是创伤的结果，或者我们甚至不知道？你知道，我认为有相对充分的证据表明BPD和人格障碍总体上有55%的遗传性。所以这些冲动性、情绪失调的特征，你知道，大多数BPD患者被描述为具有敏感气质的人。从他们年轻时起，他们就表现出我们总是提到的“薄皮”，你知道，他们的感情很容易受到伤害，很容易感到被他人轻视。所以我确实认为存在一种气质性的生物学成分。玛莎·莱恩汉（Marsha Linehan）的理论——玛莎·莱恩汉开发了辩证行为疗法，这是BPD的主要治疗方法之一——玛莎·莱恩汉的理论被称为BPD的生物-心理-社会理论。她承认BPD有很强的生物学成分，
I usually look at some of the protective factors in order to decide, is this a young person who's going to be stuck, or is this the young person who is going to show the normative decrease? And so I would say to a parent, you know, your child meets five criteria for BPD right now, but I don't think it's going to stay because I can see that, the child is getting a lot of scaffolding at home. You're slowing down a lot around emotional content. You're patient with her. You stay with her. You validate her emotions. You're here seeking help from us. That's a good sign. We need to make sure that she has a life, that she continues to do sports and cultural activities so that she continues to feel engaged. Here are all the things
我认为数据已经证实了这一点。但世界上有很多人带着敏感的气质，却并没有患上BPD。这些人通常是在一种照料环境中长大的，在这种环境中，父母以某种方式找到了耐心和储备来与那种气质达成平衡。你知道，过去曾有一段时间，父母因人格障碍而受到指责，我很高兴我们已经过去了。我有时在临床医生中仍然看到这种情况，无论我走到哪里，我都试图推广这样一种观念：父母不应为人格障碍的发展负责，因为抚养一个高度敏感气质的孩子是非常困难的。
that we can do to scaffold the personality consolidation. But sometimes I see a young person who doesn't have that protective factors. And then I would tell the parent, you know, I do think there is some risk here that she can get stuck and that she can't, she won't sort of get relief from these symptoms as she age out of adolescence. But here's what I think we need to do in order to make sure that she shows the normative decrease that her peers would. So I think that becomes the clinician's decision point, you know, is what other protective factors are in the environment to help a young person follow her peers down the normative trend versus get stuck and continue to have this elevation of borderline traits through through adolescence and young adulthood.
他们确实对父母要求更多。而且，你知道，我清楚地记得一位母亲曾经告诉我，她有一个患有BPD的年轻人，她说，你知道，当我让她把鞋子收好时，她会觉得那是在否定她。所以，当父母有一个皮肤非常薄、气质非常敏感的孩子时，他们必须付出更多的努力来真正放慢节奏。如果你的听众能从我多年来学到的东西中带走任何真理的碎片，那就是“放慢节奏”。那么，你如何要求一个气质敏感的孩子把鞋子收好呢？
So I want to talk a little bit more about parental involvement here. and I'm wondering about the theories around the causes of BPD. So is it, if you happen to be the child of, say, a parent who is borderline, might you learn those behaviors and begin to exhibit them yourself as a young person, or is it the result of trauma, or do we not even know? You know, I think there is a relatively good evidence to suggest a 55% heritability for BPD and for personality disorder in general. So these traits of impulsivity, of emotion dysregulation, you know, most young people who, and people with BPD are described as people who have a
大多数父母，包括我，只会说“把你的鞋子收好”。但如果你意识到你有一个气质敏感的孩子，那么你将不得不说，你知道，我可以看到你现在正忙着玩iPad。我们一会儿会有客人来。我能请你把鞋子收好吗？所以你可以看到，这比“你能把鞋子收好吗”花费的时间长了100%。但当你面对一个气质敏感的孩子时，
sensitive temperament. From the time they were young, they evidenced what we always refer to as thin skin, you know, their feelings are hurt easily and they feel slighted easily by others. And so I do think there is a temperamental biological component. Marsha Linehan's theory, Marsha Linehan developed dialectical behavior therapy, which is one of the main therapy approaches for BPD. And Marsha Linehan's theory is called a bio-psychosocial theory for BPD. And she acknowledged that there's a strong biological component to BPD,
你将不得不放慢节奏，你将不得不把时间安排进你的日程中，以创造一个不会让年轻人感到被否定的环境。当然，也要有必要的平衡，你也不能有一个放任自流的环境，什么都可以。你作为父母必须非常努力地在“我验证你的想法，但作为父母我也有需求，我们的环境也有需要遵守的需求和规则”之间取得平衡。但“放慢节奏”是我给气质敏感孩子的父母的主要建议。你今天在当下放慢节奏所花费的时间，在未来几年里，当你避免了住院治疗和所有伴随BPD年轻人而来的危机时，你将节省百倍的时间。
which I think the data has borne out. But there are plenty of people who come into the world with a sensitive temperament who don't turn out to have BPD. And those are usually folks who have had a caregiving environment where the parents somehow found the patients and the reserve to meet that temperament halfway. You know, there used to be a time when parents were blamed for personality disorder and I'm so glad we passed that. I still see that sometimes among clinicians and wherever I go, I try to promote the idea that parents are not to blame for the development of personality disorder because it's very difficult to parent a child with a highly sensitive temperament.
这种方法对患有BPD的成年人有效吗？我的意思是，假设你正在与一个有很多这些特征的人建立关系，你是否必须以那种方式行事以适应他们的反应方式？绝对，绝对。所以在我最常使用的治疗方法中，它被称为心智化疗法。这种放慢节奏实际上就是我们所说的“心智化立场”。心智化立场是我们为了帮助另一个人感到被理解或
They do ask more of a parent. And, you know, I remember so clearly one mother once told me she had a young person with BPD and she said, you know, when I asked her to put her shoes away, she would find that invalidating. And so a parent has to work so much harder when they have a child with very, very thin skin, with very, very sensitive temperament to really slow down. And that's if your audience can take away any nugget of truth that I've learned over the years, it's slowing down. So how do you ask a child with a sensitive temperament to put their shoes away?
被验证而采取的立场。如果你使用DBT语言，你会说你让另一个人感到被验证。在MBT（心智化疗法）语言中，我们说我们让一个人感到被理解。BPD患者几乎有一种被误解的生存感。他们感到非常疏离，不仅是与社会、与家人，而且与他们自己。他们觉得在自己的身体里没有归属感。他们觉得在自己的身体里不舒服，这是一种非常非常孤独的存在。所以家庭成员和BPD患者的治疗师可以做的是帮助他们感到被理解。而我们只有在放慢节奏时才能帮助人们感到被理解。当我们把我们的想法摆在桌面上说，你知道，这对我来说是一个两难境地。一方面，我觉得我想在这方面帮助你，
Most parents, including me, will just say put your shoes away. but if you're aware that you have a child with sensitive temperament, then you are going to have to say, you know, I can see that you're busy with your iPad right now. We're going to have guests coming over in a few moments. Can I ask you that you put your shoes away? So you can see that took longer, 100% longer than can you please put your shoes away. But when you're dealing with a child with a sensitive temperament,
另一方面，我觉得我不想干涉你正在忙的事情。这让我们处于什么境地？通过这样把你的想法摆在桌面上，通过解释而不是跳到结论或走捷径，你会在沟通的接收者心中灌输一种被理解的感觉。所以绝对，你是绝对正确的，金，无论是对孩子，还是对我们生活中的成年人，甚至是治疗师。我们放慢节奏。这是与BPD患者相处的唯一途径。
you're going to have to slow down and you're going to have to build into your schedule, time to create an environment that doesn't feel invalidating to the young person. Of course, with the necessary balance as well, you can't have a laissez-faire environment either where anything goes. You'll have to just work really hard as a parent to get the balance right between I'm validating where you might be coming from, but I also have needs as a parent and our environment has needs and rules that need to be followed. But slow, Down is the main advice that I have for parents with children with sensitive temperament. The time that you take to slow down in the moment today, you're going to save 100-fold over
最后一个大问题，BPD的关键研究领域是什么？我们绝对必须将该领域转向维度系统。所以我们必须摆脱类别。我希望下次和你交谈时，我甚至不再谈论BPD。我谈论的是广义的人格问题，或人格困难，或人格挑战，或非适应性自我和人际功能，而不是谈论BPD。我认为BPD已经变得如此被污名化。
in years to come when you're avoiding inpatient treatment and all the kind of crises that go with a young person with BPD. Does that same approach work with an adult who has BPD? I mean, let's say you're in a relationship with somebody who has a lot of these characteristics. characteristics, do you have to behave in that way in order to accommodate the way that they react? Absolutely, absolutely. So in the therapy approach that I use most often is called mentalization-based therapy. And this slowing down is really what we call the mentalizing stance. And the mentalizing stance is the stance that we take in order to help another person feel understood or
我们对BPD和BPD患者有太多错误的观念，要理解我们所有人都有自我和人际关系糟糕的日子。没有人能总是完美地管理他们的人际关系。这是我们每天面临的最大挑战。是的，患有BPD或人格障碍的人会有更多与人发生冲突的时刻，但我们所有人都能感同身受，将这一点放在同一个维度上，并承认典型和非典型人格功能之间的连续性，这就是我们需要前进的方向。
validated. If you use DBT language, you would say you make another person feel validated. In MBT language, mentalization-based therapy language, we say we make a person feel understood. People with BPD have almost an existential feeling of being misunderstood. They feel very alienated, not only from society, from their family members, but also from themselves. They don't feel homie in their own bodies. They don't feel comfortable in their own bodies and it's a very, very lonely existence. And so what family members can do and therapists for people with BPD is to help them feel understood. And we only help people feel understood when we slow down. And when we put our mind on the table and say, you know, this is a dilemma for me. On the one hand, I feel I want to help you with this.
得到验证。如果你使用DBT（辩证行为疗法）的术语，你会说你让另一个人感到被验证。在MBT（心智化临床治疗）的术语中，我们说我们让一个人感到被理解。边缘型人格障碍（BPD）患者几乎有一种存在主义式的被误解感。他们感到非常疏离，不仅是与社会、与家人疏离，甚至与他们自己也感到疏离。他们在自己的身体里感到不自在。他们在自己的身体里感到不舒服，这是一种非常、非常孤独的存在状态。因此，家人和治疗师能为BPD患者所做的，就是帮助他们感到被理解。而我们只有在放慢节奏时，才能帮助人们感到被理解。当我们把自己的想法摆在桌面上，说：你知道，这对我来说是一个两难的境地。一方面，我觉得我想在这件事上帮助你。
on the other hand, I feel I don't want to interfere with what you're busy with. Where does that leave us? In putting your mind on the table like that, in explaining rather than jumping to conclusions or taking shortcuts, you instill in the recipient of your communication a feeling of being understood. So absolutely, you're absolutely right, Kim, for both for children, but also for adults in our lives, but also therapists. We slow down. it's the only way to go with people with with BPD.
另一方面，我觉得我不想干涉你正在忙的事情。这让我们处于什么境地？通过这样把你的想法摆在桌面上，通过解释而不是妄下结论或走捷径，你会在沟通的接收者心中灌输一种被理解的感觉。所以绝对没错，金，无论是对孩子，还是对我们生活中的成年人，甚至是治疗师，都是如此。我们放慢节奏，这是与BPD患者相处的唯一途径。
Last big question, what are the next areas of critical research for BPD? We absolutely have to move the field to the dimensional system. So we have to get away from the categories. And I hope the next time I speak with you, I don't even talk about BPD anymore. And I talk about personality problems writ large or personal. personality difficulties or personality challenges or maladaptive self and interpersonal functioning rather than talking about BPD. I think BPD has become so stigmatized.
最后一个大问题，BPD研究的下一个关键领域是什么？我们绝对必须将该领域转向维度系统。所以我们必须摆脱类别。我希望下次和你交谈时，我甚至不再谈论BPD。我谈论的是广义上的人格问题，或者人格困难，或者人格挑战，或者适应不良的自我和人际功能，而不是谈论BPD。我认为BPD已经被严重污名化了。
We have so many wrong ideas about BPD and people with BPD that and to understand that all of us have bad self and interpersonal days. None of us can always be perfect in our management of interpersonal relationships. It's our biggest challenge every day. And yes, people will. with BPD or with personality disorder will have more occasions when they lose it with people, but we all can relate to that and to put that on the same dimension and to acknowledge the continuum between typical and atypical personality functioning is where we need to go.
我们对BPD和BPD患者有太多错误的观念，我们需要理解我们所有人都有自我和人际关系糟糕的日子。我们没有人能在处理人际关系时总是做到完美。这是我们每天面临的最大挑战。是的，患有BPD或人格障碍的人会有更多与人发生冲突的时刻，但我们都能感同身受。将这些放在同一个维度上，并承认典型与非典型人格功能之间的连续性，才是我们未来需要努力的方向。
So I think there's a lot of empirical research in support of these ideas. What we now need is the treatment research that shows that when we use the dimension to identify people into our randomized control trials for personality pathology treatment. We have the same effects as when we categorize people into BPD and we enroll them into our treatment trials. So I think the next big step for us is to do randomized controlled trials with alternative model defined personality disorder and not the old categories. That's definitely the biggest new challenge for us. Well, Dr. Sharp, this has been really interesting. I appreciate you're taking the time to talk to me today and to explain this really complicated disorder. Really, thank you so much.
所以我认为有很多实证研究支持这些观点。我们现在需要的是治疗研究，以证明当我们使用这一维度来筛选参与人格病理治疗随机对照试验的人员时，其效果与我们将人们归类为边缘性人格障碍（BPD）并将其纳入治疗试验的效果相同。因此，我认为我们下一步的重大举措是利用替代模型定义的人格障碍，而不是旧的分类方法来进行随机对照试验。这绝对是我们面临的最大新挑战。夏普博士，这次谈话非常有趣。感谢您抽出时间与我交谈，并解释这种非常复杂的疾病。真的非常感谢您。
Thank you. It was my pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.spokenof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyin. Thank you for listening. The American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢，这是我的荣幸。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 以及其他任何您获取播客的平台上找到《心理学谈话》往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的内容，请留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作，我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康丁。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。